- No, but have you ever
met any of the cast
before doing the movie?
- I used to work at the Four Seasons Hotel
in Beverly Hills so I used to
wait on some of these guys.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- [Sebastian] As a waiter
I used to --
- [Kelly] Both waiters!
Get it, get it!
- [Sebastian] Yeah, hello.
Love the waiters.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- Seven and a half years.
- Tip them!
They hate their lives, secretly.
(laughing loudly)
- But you waited on who?
- I waited on anywhere
from Nicole Kidman--
- Wow.
- to Al Pacino to Robert De Niro
and fast forward now 2019, 20,
I'm in a movie with these guys.
So, I worked there, yeah.
- That's so cool!
(people clapping)
- Yeah, it's crazy.
- I love you telling that story
because I think a lot of people out there
start to give up. They start
to give up and they go,
"Whatever, okay, I'll
lean into something else.
"My backup plan or something."
And that's a really incredible story,
that's really inspiring.
- Yeah, well I had no backup plan.
- I didn't either.
(laughing loudly)
- Yeah.
It was either this or
the streets.
- [Kelly] Just sink.
(laughing loudly)
- So, yeah.
When I came out to LA in 1998,
it was stand-up comedy or bus.
So yeah, I worked there
seven and half years
waited on all of Hollywood, and--
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- Now things
are finally paying off, so yeah.
- I bet you all of them were
waiters at some point, too.
I feel like we all were waiters.
Were you a good waiter?
- I was not only a waiter,
I was selling satellite dishes--
(laughing loudly)
out of a kiosk in the ghetto.
So--
- I sold vacuum cleaners for 2 days.
- Is that right?
- Uh huh, and I was like
"I'm out."
- Door to door?
- Mm hmm.
- Yeah.
- The dirt and it was
like, "You know what? "No."
I couldn't do it.
- Yeah.
We all had these jobs I used to glaze ham
at Honey Baked Ham.
- Oh my gosh, those are good!
(people cheering)
- Honey Baked Ham, look.
- Those are good!
I'm serious.
- This one is like, "Yeah!
"Ham!"
(laughing loudly)
- No, we get those for
Christmas and Thanksgiving.
I'm not kidding, they're so good.
- Yeah, I glazed them.
- Nicely done.
- Yeah.
- You are great at glazing.
- Thank you.
- See, it's all this that
builds to where you are now.